[Music]
with Red Dead Redemption - Rockstar
Games has set out to create its most
ambitious open-world experience to date
it is an epic tale of outlaw life that
seamlessly blends story with action
let's go click an exploration with
choice all under the constant threat of
danger the world is full of adventures
and experiences that you discover
naturally as you move fluidly from one
moment to another gentlemen you all know
what to do
Arthur can undertake a wide array of
nefarious activities with his fellow
gang members some are large-scale height
while others are more personal oh you
can rob a train passerby or a coach hold
up a store pergola house or go
loan-sharking here for money or you can
simply go off and explore alone if
you're feeling brave enough the
countryside towns and frontier are full
of rival gangs and outlaws each
different but all of them deadly how's
that score you stole offers rich one in
this rapidly civilizing world lawmen are
cunning weather tracking known outlaws
or investigating a crime scene now I'm
not a fella to pass a quick judgment I
know you don't hire a saint to catch a
sinner get a price on your head and
bounty hunters will track you down
Arthur must always be prepared to defend
himself against whatever is thrown at
them the Deadeye system has been
expanded and will progress in stages
allowing you to slow time
paint targets
and keep critical or fatal points of
your enemies how and when you use it is
up to you your experience is defined by
the choices and decisions you make for
Arthur you can of course choose what to
wear ride eat and which guns to carry
shave bathe or don't it's up to you Red
Dead Redemption too is full of things to
do
[Music]
there are countless secrets to uncover
there and people to meet you can get
into raucous altercations take in a show
chase down bounties fight a duel and a
lot more be careful out there
this is the country your behavior has
consequences and people will remember
you and your actions you can also
experience the game in first person
[Music]
or taking the world with new cinematic
cameras for some stunning views the
result is a world that is deep teeming
with life and very menacing its
consolation
[Music]
they'll probably hang you buddy
in the late 1800s America was evolving
on its way to becoming the most powerful
country in the world new immigrants
arrived thriving outposts became towns
and civilization was spreading rapidly
into the huge wild and lawless frontier
with Red Dead Redemption - Rockstar
Games aims to create a living world
that's not simply open but deeper more
interactive and detailed than ever
combining action storytelling and
gameplay in new ways as you live ride
and fight to survive as an outlaw in a
notorious gang as long as we get paid
you get shot I'm happy
the game is an attempt to capture this
pivotal moment when the age of outlaws
was ending and the modern world was born
there is a huge world to explore set
across a range of America's heartland
and frontier from harsh mountain trails
and dense forests to untamed swamp lands
and sweeping deserts rugged livestock
towns to modernizing cities and much
more all populated with a diverse cast
of characters from turn-of-the-century
life now shoo
please I'm waiting for someone
interesting to turn
you play as Arthur Morgan a trusted
senior gun in the vanderlin gang a band
about laws and outcasts on the run from
the pressures of civilized life once and
for all
[Music]
each time they're forced to flee an area
the gang sets up a camp as a base this
is where gang members eat sleep perform
chores play games and share stories by
some country sheriff's these are the
people Arthur calls family and you will
get to know each gang member over the
course of the game so you save the silly
bastards laughs and you and him go Robyn
she helping the camp with food and
supplies will keep morale high while
spending time with other gang members
can reveal new secrets fun things to do
and opportunities for mischief
redistribute some property in and out of
camp the world is alive and responds to
the player and your guns aren't the only
way to interact with the environment
call out to a passing rider talk
yourself into trouble with a local tough
guy or out of trouble with a town
sheriff or intimidate a witness into
silence and more
you don't want to involve yourself with
this confrontations can be escalated or
diffused take it easy do what you want
you can form friendships or make enemies
as you choose your actions have
consequences and it's up to you to
decide just how honorable Arthur is
should I have killed you Jimmy Brooks
shooting and fighting have both been
radically improved to make combat deep
and engaging at all times each weapon
has unique characteristics with
realistic reload and recoil that always
keeps the player grounded and connected
to the action in a gunfight in a similar
way the bond with your horse is crucial
and changes based on your treatment of
the animal
some breeds are better suited for
certain tasks horse like this for a
while your saddle and saddlebags can
store extra weapons along with supplies
and animal carcasses that you pick up
while out roaming or hunting over time
the bond between you and your horse will
grow making them easier to control in
tense situations yeah he's a great horse
the devil's got him a rich and varied
ecosystem thrives in the world full of
predators prey and scavengers all smart
and sometimes deadly you wanna come with
me
hunting helps the camp or earns you
money wound an animal and you'll have to
track them down animal pelts and other
items you find can be traded for cash to
use at general stores gunsmiths saloons
and elsewhere this is God's own country
and I feel I'm in purgatory this is a
world that is rich in depth and detail
all designed to be explored on horseback
or on foot as you live the fateful
journey of a gang of Outlaws on the run
across America
in the next gameplay video we'll look at
missions activities enemy gangs
robberies other things to do and much
more including the evolution of
sharpshooting using the dead eyes system
[Music]
you